[Music]
[Applause]
mike florio joins us pro football talk
live co-host and that book playmakers if
you don't have it what's wrong with you
available online wherever books are sold
he pulls back the curtain on the nfl
mike good to talk to you how are you dan
i'm doing great how are you uh yeah as
you can tell you know we're preparing
for our speech but we see you next week
at the sports no okay i don't go
anywhere anymore okay all right it would
be nice to have some support there oh
i'll support you from afar okay
all the best i'm trying to believe fritz
you'll show up with a limerick oh my god
mike there we go oh no thank you mike
the door has been opened todd he was
kidding oh wow yeah i think he was
telling you we're kidding i was kidding
i'm kidding todd
dawn todd that means he doesn't want you
to show up with a limerick talent
i didn't pick up on that i thought he
was encouraging me to write a limber you
can write a limerick thanks go ahead
go ahead i'm on it you can write a limit
all right mike uh help me understand
here the nfl declines comments on the
report of a meeting with deshaun watson
okay
tell me what is supposed to be could be
happening in this meeting between the
two
well this seems to be the traditional
meeting that the nfl would engage in
interviewing fact-finding questioning
challenging getting to the bottom of the
allegations pending against desean
watson the league's habit dan is to wait
until the end of the process to meet
with the person who is accused of
wrongdoing i don't think they have to do
that they could meet with him multiple
times if they want to and sometimes it's
smart you meet with the accused you find
out some facts you go back to the
accusers you flush things out you meet
with the accused again the idea of
putting all the eggs in one basket and
waiting till the end i don't know that i
agree with but that's what the nfl does
and it tells me that at some point
a decision is coming and when you look
at the timeline the next few months are
going to go quickly we're going to be in
training camp in two months the regular
season opener is 17 weeks away it's time
for the nfl to make some decisions they
like to delay making a decision as long
as they possibly can but you got the
browns trying to get people to buy
single game tickets i'd like to know
before i give you my credit card
information cleveland browns who the
quarterback is going to be and at some
point the nfl just needs to make a
decision and when you consider the
procedure they have in place now it's
going to take some time and if they want
to get this all buttoned up before week
one it's time to start making some
decisions about what they're going to do
about desean watson for 2022. and this
meeting tells me the next step maybe
friday memorial day weekend a little bad
news dump in the afternoon coming up in
about 10 days maybe that's when we find
out what the league is planning to do
can desean watson and his lawyers say
we're not going to cooperate
well they can but
it's not going to go well for him he's
required to cooperate there's no fifth
amendment protection and if he chooses
not to cooperate they'll go ahead and
make their decision and they'll use his
refusal to cooperate against him it
would be along the same lines of the tom
brady destroyed cell phone from seven
years ago it would definitely enhance
the penalties if he says i'm not talking
to you now you pointed out by saying the
league is not required to wait until the
22 cases are resolved before they
suspend deshaun watson your guess is the
league will suspend him now with the
possibility of suspending him again
later why do you feel that way that's a
guess because it allows them
to
deal with the facts as they currently
understand them to be and this is a guy
who's accused by 22 different people of
wrongdoing this isn't one or two this is
22. at some point between 1 and 22 the
standard well you know we need to hear
both sides of this well it could be
somebody who's out to get some at 22 i
don't know where the number is but at 22
you're on the wrong side of the number
where you've reached a critical mass
where there's just too many people to
dismiss it as a conspiracy or a money
grab or whatever 22 is too many so they
could say
just based on what we already know just
based on the lifestyle you've admitted
to
finding these massages via social media
his lawyer rusty harden has admitted
that some of those massages would become
consensual sexual encounters those
habits are enough that it requires
intervention it requires a suspension so
we're going to do
a suspension for now
and we're gonna monitor these cases and
depending upon how they turn out we may
suspend you again later that would be
i think a safe balance for the nfl you
take some action now and then you wait
and see what happens with the cases and
maybe you take action later
can the nfl talk to stephen ross and the
dolphins
now correct me if i'm wrong here but
didn't they sort of have a negotiation
that they were going to trade for watson
but he could only settle 18 of the 22
cases
is that right
well they were going to trade for watson
if he settled all of the cases and 18 of
them were ready to go there were four
holdouts and watson decided if i can't
sell them all i'm not settling any and i
think that was a bad decision in
hindsight i think if you take 18 of
these cases off the table it's a lot
more manageable if you only have four
even if they are the four strongest
claims and i don't know which four were
the holdouts but take away the 18 for or
left the dolphins believed
that if deshawn watson had settled all
22 and the trade had happened he would
have been suspended six games i don't
know why they believe it the league is
very good about keeping cards close to
the vest but the dolphins believed he
was looking at a six-game suspension if
he settled all 22
and uh and and i don't know why the
dolphins think that again but uh you
know the league can talk to whoever they
want to talk to to try to get to the
bottom of this and come up with the best
punishment but i think that that the
dolphins were just making their
decisions based upon whatever they
managed to get from the league office
any chance deshawn watson is not
suspended at some point
well the only way that would happen is
if the nfl decides to do nothing now
let the 22 cases play out
he wins
22 different
trials which good luck with that dan i
tried more cases than i care to remember
because if you try cases for a living
you know we see in tvs and movies oh
he's never lost a case oh never lost a
case you know what if you've never lost
a case you never tried a case you tried
only one and you got lucky because by
the time a case goes to trial it is a
complete and total crap shoot flip of
the coin
so many factors are out of your control
you're going to try 22 of these cases
you're going to win 22 good freaking
luck with that but let's assume that
happens they decide to wait he wins all
22 coin flips
and then they say what do we what are we
suspending him for he's he's not
responsible for any violations of
anyone's rights that would be the only
way that he's not suspended at all he's
mike florio his best-selling book
playmakers available online wherever
books are sold as a uh lawyer what did
you think of joe
pesci's performance in my cousin vinnie
oh that was awesome hey dan listen
i would
when i was getting ready to try case
i would watch my cousin vinnie and a few
good men because of all the more the
movies and tv shows i've ever seen over
the years those were the two that were
the most realistic
my cousin vinnie is uncannily accurate
what as to how yes i mean you don't have
a lawyer that over the top but the the
procedural aspects of it the way that it
unfolded was very accurate very accurate
whoever wrote that script either was a
lawyer or knew a lawyer very well
but i would always try to strike that
balance because at the end of the day
you're trying to just like you do every
day like i try to do every morning on
pft live you got to keep the jury
entertained they expect to be
entertained they fall asleep quickly and
between a few good men and my cousin
vinnie i would find the inspiration to
go in
and hopefully keep the jury awake at
least until the end of the opening
statements did you ever sometimes i was
successful did you ever yell objection
i did want to say everything that guy
said is bull
oh
stuff no i never said that oh i i you
know you get into you got to do you got
to you got to entertain them they expect
you think about it you're you're a
member of a jury and you've heard all
this stuff over the years you've seen
all these shows and movies you expect to
be entertained so it's a high bar and uh
you know you got to come up with some
ways to keep their attention were you
ever held in contempt
i was not no i was not i i don't think i
was ever even close i i got i got
chastised a few times because when
you're in trial especially if you
practice alone you're sleeping like four
hours a night during trial i mean it is
all-encompassing it is stressful and so
sometimes you get into stress a little
bit and i i pissed a few judges off in
my time all right tell me what's going
on with drew brees and nbc since you
work with him on football night in
america mike hey hey hey dan
they they only wake me up for the
unimportant meetings i don't know
anything i do know this though i do know
this
i i have no reason to doubt the
reporting from andrew marchand to the
new york post when he says the
relationship is over and when drew brees
tweets that it's speculation drew it's
not speculation it's a report and i
suspect he's frustrated that he didn't
get to control his narrative so he came
out with this tweet that suggests he
could do all sorts of different things i
don't think he's joking i think he can
do whatever he wants to do if he wants
to play football he could play right now
there's teams that i would look at their
depth chart and say he would be the best
option if he walked through the door
right now seattle
carolina miami
sorry two of two anon but if he really
wanted to do it yeah and if he wants to
play pickleball professionally yeah he
could probably do it if he wants to be
on the senior pga tour i mean he's seven
years too young but he'd have seven
years to get ready and he'd probably be
good enough to do it so i i i have no
reason to think that andrew marshawn's
report is inaccurate but uh i also
would be surprised if he comes back and
plays football the thing that i brought
up yesterday and i went back and
listened to an interview i did with him
in november of 2021 and he talked about
the
that excitement when you go to a stadium
to be an analyst as opposed to a sterile
environment in stanford connecticut
where you're around you and peter king
and chris no offense that's not yeah
that's not a selling point he's used to
being out there hearing the crowd
whether they're yelling at him or for
him
and i think that's what he truly misses
he needs that
he feeds off of that i don't think he's
going to play again but i do think he
looks around and goes i don't want to be
a studio guy
and if i'm going to make money i got to
make money as an analyst because that's
where everybody's making all their money
what do you think of that logic i think
you're right it's a different world when
you're in studio remember when we were
in 30 rock and there were no windows
there was no natural light there was no
fresh air there were no clocks it was
like being trapped in a casino somewhere
you had no idea whether it was day or
night it was just a weird suffocating
claustrophobic environment so different
than being in an open-air stadium with
all those people there the environment
you're used to for 25 years of your life
between college and pros yeah i think he
i don't think it's a secret that he
wants to do games
there's no games in nbc for him to do so
he's going to have to look elsewhere and
that's why you know fox the musical
chairs
they're still not full yet there's still
a spot in the second or third slot there
and
if that's what he wants to do that seems
to be what he's what he's destined to do
so you think dan orlovsky then will
replace drew brees at nbc oh i don't hey
they don't tell me anything i love your
reaction i love your i don't know they
don't tell me they don't tell me but
you're a reporter
you have to find this out
okay i'm on it
now you're on it
it's it's a delicate
situation as you might imagine
thank you thank you for shying away from
a delicate information can i close with
a limerick
yeah yeah of course you have one i had
one the other day for fritzy i didn't
hear i thought i'd get a text from him i
thought i had a seaton liked it i had a
good limerick for fritzy i can't
remember what it is now
wait you wrote it and sent it to fritzy
well i i wrote it and tweeted it to
fritz
uh i don't think i saw that i totally
would have responded i'd never blow off
mike he gets back to me immediately when
we invite him on the show i didn't text
it to you i thought you'd see it on
twitter seaton liked it seton enjoyed it
i think
seton
yeah kind of remember something about
that wow oh it was a few days ago wow it
really it really made it
quite a bit of courtesy like you're like
oh yeah i like that mic is involved but
wow okay i know where i stand that's
right
it feels go back to the lab go ears
feels like how about frizzy i'll write
your limits i'll send you 10 limericks
that you can use from the podium when
you guys win next i would love that he
doesn't use other people's work that's
the problem like no matter how good it
is that's definitely the problem well i
did i said to sandler and david spade
would you write some material for fritzy
when he does stand up and they said
absolutely and i said to fritzy hey good
news sandler and spade will write some
of your material goes um
i'd rather they didn't and i go are you
kidding me so he'd rather go down in
flames with his material than to get
props for your material yeah i get that
i get that there's a pride in authorship
even if there's no pride in your
authorship ultimately you want to be the
one responsible for the laughs or the
lack thereof i get that
by the way i still hold to uh my theory
that uh the browns hold on to uh to
baker mayfield because if desean watson
is suspended for six games eight games
baker gets to come in they try to make
nice with him to say here
you're able to play for your next job do
your best go out there prove you can
play and we'll send you you know
someplace uh during the season
that's the right play that is the right
play but they have a lot of damage to
undo and it's their own damn fault for
how they handled the guy but he in his
mind that bridge is obliterated the
browns have to rebuild that bridge i
mean if they would make him a promise
that they'll trade him by the trade
deadline if it's less than a eight game
suspension or or we won't use the
franchise tag next year if you go out
and have a great season and we think we
can try to trade you next year something
to induce him back into the family
because dan seattle carolina cleveland
if those are ultimately his three
options cleveland's the best place where
he could have the kind of season that
sets the table for the contract he wants
to get next year seaton without question
do you have florio's limerick i do all
right i do
uh it says there once was a man named
fritz who wanted to give his friend to
fitz he wrote up some jokes shared them
with his blokes and someday they'll
laugh till they explode
oh
[Laughter]
see on our show i could say the word we
said it three times today because we're
not fcc regulated anymore
sims swears all the time doesn't he we i
he well not all the time
well all the time off air yes
on air it's creeping in more and more
and we've got this test going like
we keep dropping s and f bombs until
somebody says something and nobody said
anything which i guess means nobody's
watching
well that's that was our approach on
sportscenter when i was with oberman we
thought let's
let's just say whatever we want to say
and see if we hear from management
and when we didn't hear from management
we just figured they weren't up at 11
o'clock at night you know which was like
uh fun but kind of scary that management
wasn't even listening to us uh the book
is playmakers pick it up you'll love it
and a great father's day gift as well
mike thank you as always and keep those
limericks
to yourself thank you dan all right
that's mike floyd yes yeah what did you
think of that fritzy i thought florio
did a pretty good i actually liked it a
lot i liked that there was a little
little humor in there